but you severed our last long talk of
the day by over hoose on statistical
analysis of performance scaling thank
you it had to be here so I want to start
this by just acknowledging that you know
I had the great opportunity and the joy
to work together with some very talented
people on most of the work that I'm
going to talk about here they are
you might recognize one or the other and
I try to call out their contributions as
we go through so what's the best
algorithm for matrix multiplication
anybody knows currently not sure that
I'm up to speed so I thought I'd check
with you so any theories takers no all
right I think it's this one yes La Liga
2014 and it's all of into the two point
three seven two eight six three nine
all these decimals are pretty important
because that was an improvement over
what was that's the year before by
Virginia Russell Esther Williams into
the two point three seven two eight
seven three so there's a difference in
the fifth decimal in that exponent there
and all these with these methods and
some others I actually based on a
breakthrough method by coppersmith and
we know grant from 1990 which achieves
or of n to the two three seven six and
that was actually the first major
breakthrough after the algorithm by
focusing from 1969 and as I was digging
this up I found something very
interesting namely that Strassen
originally was a statistician and he
actually discovered this algorithm here
in Berkeley while he was visiting in
1968 just around the time when my
parents would have discovered me so I
feel very related to this and it's
interesting because essentially these
three algorithms are the state of the
art but nobody uses them and the reason
for that is that the constants that are
hidden in the Big O notation are so big
that some people who looked at this in
detail determined
and I actually was corresponding with
Virginia Williams about this as well
that these algorithms on modern
computers in the foreseeable future will
never actually be practical because the
constants are too big so what do people
really do when they multiply matrices
and I think we all do they use I -
Classon or in fact if numerical
stability is an issue they use the naive
of N cubed and that's where we are so
this is not this theoreticians at all
but it's to point out that within this
Big O notation sometimes important
things get hidden or neglected and we
sometimes tend to forget about that and
it's good to be aware of this now of
course the other thing that I should
point out is that the Big O notation
sometimes does give us pretty nice
results for instance for 3sat there is a
very nice result from 2011 by teaming
Hadley Robin Moser and Dominic shader
that shows that 3sat in the worst case
can be solved in oh of 1.3 to 0-6 5 to
the N which is a lot better than 2 to
the N actually if you graph this or
calculate it you'll see that this
actually makes a huge difference doesn't
explain quite why modern Sat solver are
so amazingly effective but it makes you
realise that sometimes you can be a lot
better of course then you naively think
and this actually M does mean a little
bit more although nobody uses that
algorithm either
okay so we're all interested in
algorithmics that's sort of the
interests that we share and algorithmics
has two branches analysis where we
assess characterize and ultimately hope
to predict performance and design where
we build algorithms with desirable
properties and ultimately we're
interested in optimizing performance in
some meaningful way right and that's the
quest on which all these people whose
results I just mentioned have been I do
empirical algorithmics which is exactly
the same thing has exactly the same
motivation but it uses principle
techniques from statistics and heavily
relies on tools for machine learning and
optimization to talk about algorithms
that are otherwise weakly accessible or
inaccessible to conventional analysis
also to talk about the constants that
often are actually important so the rest
of this talk will be about empirical
algorithmics there's two things that I
want to share with you today the first
one is about analysis and the second one
is about design so let's talk about
analysis first you all know the TSP I
don't have to introduce that formally a
bunch of cities we assume that they're
in the plane just to keep things simple
and actually we will assume for the rest
of this talk that they're in a unit
square in the plane and that they've
been randomly sprinkled there although
we relax this assumption a little bit
later
and we want to find a shortest round
trip that visits every city exactly once
so there's a famous and very good book
on the TSP by David Applegate at all
from 2006 and in this book they provide
a lot of interesting theory a lot of
very interesting pragmatic approaches
and in the end they come up with an
algorithm that actually still is up to
the state the state of the art in exact
TSP solving so if you want provably
optimal tours that's what you use it's
called concorde and then they evaluate
this and empirically because they want
to know how well it actually performs
and so what they do is they generate
these are you a random uniform Euclidian
instances 10,000 of them up to a size of
about 1000 and then they drop the number
of samples to 1,000 because it becomes
pretty expensive and here they show us
the the mean of the number of CPU
seconds it takes to solve these
instances and you can see that it starts
pretty harmless with a hundred cities
and then it goes pretty big at 2,500 as
of course we would expect right and so
then they show a nice graph like this
and they say about the graph the plot of
the mean values and this figure
indicates that the running times are
increasing as an exponential function of
n can you all see that it's it's a semi
log plot right and they're essentially
saying this thing this curve here levels
off asymptotically approaches a straight
line and therefore it's exponential
scaling which is what you would kind of
expect from a TSP algorithm right
so what I want to argue is that this is
pretty much what most people do to
empirically characterize the scaling of
performance to do the empirical
equivalent of a big ol analysis for
running time but I will argue that you
can do a lot better and I think doing a
lot better has a lot of benefits and
relatively modest costs and so the first
thing we should realize is that really
when we talk about scaling we talk about
models right and the model that these
folks you have in mind is this one here
eight times B to the N a tumor from a
parameter exponential model because
that's exactly what corresponds to the
straight lines in the semi log plot now
in statistics and in general in science
it's always good to not just have one
model but to compare models right
because ultimately you want to see
whether one model is better than another
it's very difficult to evaluate models
in the absolute we'll come to a point
pretty soon where we can do this in this
particular setting but it's very nice to
be comparing models because that makes
life typically easier and so just for
the heck of it we'll throw in a
polynomial model here also two
parameters so that it has the same
degree of freedom eight times n to the B
so it's actually a monomial model but we
all know what what we mean here right
and so here is another plot of this a
little cleaner because I recreated it
from the data in the table and so now we
can try to formally understand how they
come to a conclusion that there's
exponential model fits well by actually
fitting an exponential model using a
normal numerical fitting procedure
numerical optimization procedure to
determine the to the the two parameter
values for a two parameter exponential
model and the red curve is what you get
and that's probably exactly what these
guys drew by hand and set to a clearly
is exponential right and you can see
that too now what's interesting is first
of all you might wonder why does it fit
so well here and not so well there
that's because we doing these squares
fitting and here the numbers the the
differences are very small here the
differences and you can't see very much
right they would have to be very big
indeed to see them so it really kind of
intuitively focuses on this reference
here representation on fitting these
points well which is a useful thing
so what happens if we fit the polynomial
model just for the heck of it look how
interesting that is the green curve
right the green curve intuitively fits
the data points as well as the red line
but qualitatively shows an interesting
behavior here that actually kind of
qualitatively mirrors what the real
curve is doing while the red curve is
not doing not so in already one sense
that green model is better but of course
that's not how we evaluate models how do
we really evaluate models what would you
do if you have to quantitatively do this
very good so you use the model to
extrapolate right and in fact I mean you
could have said interpolate but you said
extrapolate and the reason for that is
that the reason we do scaling analysis
is we can't because we want to make
inferences about instances that are so
large that it becomes very expensive to
do experiments on them right that's much
more useful than doing experiment for a
point in between here right and that's
why extrapolations exactly what you want
to do but first of all if you don't do
extrapolation the classical thing you
would do is RMS a right root mean square
error to just see how well you fit the
data that's the first thing and so it
turns out that with the RMS II the
exponential model is slightly better
than the polynomial model right so you
could on that basis and without having
you're clever sort prefer the
exponential model slightly so now we're
going to do what you said exactly we
want to challenge the model by
extrapolation and we do this by
measuring two more data points here and
here okay and notice since the TSP the
running times get quick get get big
pretty quickly we fitted the model only
up to here to 1500 so 2500 it's not just
a thousand larger it's almost twice as
large with something that has
exponential scaling or about exponential
scaling so it's a pretty significant
extrapolation challenge and so you can
already see this false short of the red
line it also falls above the green line
and now we can look at our MSE on those
predictions right and that's arguably a
better measure than our MSE on the data
that we have just fit it so let's do
and to our surprise the polynomial model
now appears quite a bit better than the
exponential model okay so in that sense
the polynomial model is actually better
than the exponential model for this
algorithm so this is interesting and
unexpected so maybe we need a third
model that is a little bit more precise
now right because somehow this is in
between exponential and polynomial and
what you might have guessed you could
use is indeed this one here square root
exponential model and if you fit this
you will see the blue curve almost
perfectly hits those points and actually
the RMS is an order of magnitude better
than both of these other models right so
I would claim this is already a more
scientific way of talking about
empirical scaling models there's the
really small constant on your polynomial
make you nervous at all I mean maybe it
should so we'll we'll get back to that
point but this is a good observation
right so the the first thing that I want
to point out though is even if we
believe that you know the exponential
it's maybe a safe upper bound look at
the nature of this exponential fifteen
point zero four times one point zero
zero six three to the N we have to live
with exponential that's a pretty good
exponential to have I hope we can agree
on that and the polynomial is also not
that bad it's just a very small constant
as cliff pointed out times n to the four
essentially so it's pretty good pretty
good scaling behavior right yes and
that's essentially what everybody who's
doing TSP algorithms research with an
empirical slant has been studying a lot
of theoretical work I think has been
focusing on that model as well so it's a
well-established benchmark not believed
to be a typically easy and I would give
you some evidence for this not typically
easy in a moment okay good so now if you
want to further challenge the models
right for instance to see whether that
small constant here should make us
nervous what you should do is measure a
larger data points that there comes a
big problem with that in that actually
behind every single one of these data
points is a large set of instances and
there's quite a bit of variability in
difficulty in these instances we'll get
back to that later as well but for now
just take my word for it that some of
these instances at 2,500 are actually in
order of magnitude harder and so as we
go further up and
challenge the models more we will
actually have runs that never terminate
because we just can't afford to run them
forever right
and so therefore we now switch from the
mean to the median because the median is
not only statistically more stable but
also of course handled sensor data very
gracefully because it can just cut it
off until you heat you reach 50% sensor
data and so here it's now observed media
and running times we can now go to four
thousand five hundred so three times as
large as the largest size that we've
ever used for learning about the scaling
behavior right so this is very massive
extrapolation and so we have an
exponential model and it's predictions
here our bet fits best with exponential
model we have our observations this
shows you how many instances actually
completed but because we're using
medians we don't have to be concerned
this is still statistically very safely
away from the 50% point this is our
polynomial model and this is the root
exponential model you can see that the
root exponential model is actually
pretty close to the actual observations
here right so almost on the dot for 2000
almost on the dot for 3000 and very
close for 4500 still right so this is
actually very good for an empirical
scaling model and it might make you
wonder whether there's a fundamental
reason why it should scale that way now
I think I don't see him here but I think
what a few actually at least knows about
a somewhat obscure Theory result that
uses a geometric subdivision technique
to prove that in the worst case you can
solve 2d Euclidean TSP in n to the
square root of n so that's a little bit
worse than what we have here in our
would exponential model it's a log
factor but talking to the folks who did
that
Nick warmint and Warren Smith they said
to their best knowledge nobody has ever
implemented their technique it doesn't
make sense to implement it and certainly
conquered the solver that we're looking
at here the state of the art solver is
not using any of this and in fact the
makers of Concord were blissfully
unaware of this result at all so this is
interesting and there might be some
theoretical explanation for it Kevin I
should just point like this and it
doesn't fit very well so it actually
does open a gap that's I didn't show it
but it isn't as good a fit as this ok so
the real question we should be asking
though is how close is close enough
right I mean is this really a model we
should have faith in as we go further
out or perhaps not so it turns out that
you know our MSE and essentially just
comparing those numbers which is what
RMS is doing as well is a little bit
arbitrary it allows us to distinguish
between models but it doesn't give us an
absolute sense when we should trust
something right and so what we want is a
principled method for validating an
empirical scaling model okay and so here
is an observation based on which we can
actually do this so let's look behind
the data that I've shown you so far
let's run Concord once on one instance
and this is what you get here right
another one another one another one okay
so you can now see the variability that
I talked about earlier okay let's do
this for 600 700 800 900 and 1000 and
let's now boil this data down to medians
which is what we have done previously
without me showing you and then let's
collect them connect them through a line
and you can see that line is Wiggly and
the reason for that is that here I only
use something like a hundred instances
if you use a thousand instances it
becomes very nice and smooth and Eid and
so then what we did is we bit it and
that's exactly what we did before we do
a best for the exponential for example
to these medians and then we measure
again our target instances here and we
look at this median and we look at how
close is this red dot to what the model
predicts right that's what we've been
doing so far and now the key observation
is or the key question to ask is what's
the dependence of this empirical scaling
model on the given set of sample
instances right these instances that I
actually had how far do they influence
the model and that gives rise to the
idea to actually validate the model
using boots
confidence intervals by resampling those
instances you take the instances as a
surrogate for the underlying
distribution sample from it that's the
classical bootstrap idea right and then
you would look at these samples and you
see how that effects the model if you
change the sample and here's what
happens I take another sample actually
first of all let's do it for a
prediction right I take another sample
and you see that the prediction moves a
little bit I left a little trace of the
old prediction so we can keep track of
it and it moves again right and if I do
this a thousand times I get all of these
points predicted predicted right so I
get a distribution of predictions now I
can determine a confidence interval
simply by determining quantiles or
there's more sophisticated methods but
basically just from this bootstrap
distribution so in this case this is a
nine ninety-five percent simple quanta
put strapped confidence interval between
the center of this and in this little
red figure there good and now I can see
whether that media and running time
actually falls in between the two in
this case it just barely does not it
just barely falls outside of it
if that falls within that bootstrap
confidence interval in some very
meaningful way our model is in full
agreement with with what we've observed
okay so what we now get is bootstrap
confidence intervals rather than
individual model predictions okay and we
can now see whether they capture these
observed media and running times and you
can see those months for the exponential
model clearly don't
those ones for the polynomial model
clearly don't either although it's not
as far outside right and the ones for
the rude exponential model capture them
just beautifully you can also see how
much uncertainty there is as you go
further and further out in these model
predictions which previously we couldn't
see right so in reality the model is not
saying that we get you know four hundred
or three hundred and thirty-four
thousand the model says we get something
between two hundred and fifty three
thousand and seven hundred and thirty
four thousand and certainly three
hundred and forty-four is nicely within
that confidence interval so now we know
that in a very meaningful way this and
this model are not good models
and this one here in fact is the next
thing you can do is you can ask yourself
these little distributions let's go back
here what do they look like
maybe if I look at them maybe if I can
characterize them we can find something
useful and here's something that I think
you might be able to help with I
couldn't find it in the literature but
it might be in a relatively easy
theoretical argument to show that
actually the distribution of running
times of meaningful TSP algorithm should
perhaps be a lot normal because that's
exactly what we get if we do an a
Shapiro book normality test here on on
those this one here has a little bit of
a tail abnormality because that's
because the algorithm needs a certain
amount of time to really get going
so there's some sort of startup effort
that distorts the tail here but these
ones you get beautifully accepted by
Shapiro Wilks so there are really
basically perfect log normal
distributions and not only are they that
you can see in these cumulative
distribution plots that also they're
coefficient of variation is the same you
can see that because then these curves
are basically exact exact shifted copies
of each other right now once you know
this and again it would be very nice to
be able to prove it this is just an
empirical observation statistically
validated and then you can basically
have and this is a log log plot which is
why what used to be straight lines now
now is curved lines now you have
basically a prediction for the media and
you can derive from that predictions for
also for your for the 0 0 5 and 9 0 5
quantiles right and so now you get it
banned in which all these instances
should fall 95% of them and now you can
do something very interesting you can
take structure instances TSP live
instances these are not random they are
highly structured many of them actually
come from problems such as you know
drilling holes in printed circuit boards
so this is very very different in
structure from what you would expect in
a random instance because many of the
distances are exactly the same because
they're great based right or we have in
TSP Lib instances they're Geographic you
know the 532 biggest cities in the
United States and things like that and
you can see that these instances the
vast majority of them falls within the
band of predictions for random uniform
Euclidean and that is some sort of
validation for the fact that random
uniform Euclidean actually is a pretty
good model for Euclidean instances in
structure and once ok good so what about
in exact TSP solvers this was an exact
here's piece over set that gets you
probably optimal solutions state of the
art they're two algorithms EAX which is
an evolutionary algorithm which
available with a very clever and
recombination strategy very nice
algorithm no provable properties of any
interest of this highly heuristic just
like on court and using our analysis
method we can show that it's scaling can
be characterized in the media as 0.25
times 1 point 1 to 3 to the square root
of n I mean lkh plus we start and this
restart is something that we added
because we know the stagnation in both
algorithms so they actually performed
worse before we touch them but they're
very insignificant modifications this
one actually appears to be scaling
polynomially so here a polynomial model
actually fits much better than than the
squared exponential and a low degree
polynomial as well so this is trained
again on 500 to 1500 city instances and
then select the based on the best our
MSE on 2000 to 4500 but we already know
that RMS is not the best we can do so
let's look at bootstrap confidence
intervals and so I abuse notation
slightly here but just writing directly
the confidence intervals of the
parameters which you can of course
extract exactly using the same technique
right because every curve that you fit
to a resample gives you a model and so
you also get distributions over model
parameters and that's what I'm writing
here and as you can see here and
actually you get two models this one
here fits slightly better than this but
if you look at whether it passes the
challenge in terms of capturing the
predictions it turns out this one here
does capture although it has a higher
rms e it does capture and this one here
just barely captures not so this in some
sense is a lower bound right an
empirical lower bound and it's
interesting that you can also see that
lkh we start here
and tends to be a little bit better than
EAX restart and this is what you see in
practice on those instances as well all
right and so now you can have the idea
maybe Concord if I stop it once it sees
the optimal solution quality without
being able to prove that it is that it's
just as good right so you can of course
analyze that as well and you find again
that this is a square with exponential
model but it is quite a bit larger in
terms of the critical base of this
squared exponential here than those two
so it is actually worse in a very
measurable way since words and in fact I
want you to notice that this confidence
interval here is actually disjoint from
this and and this one here and this one
here is paired it is joined from this
one here yes
so in all these cases here you're aiming
to find the exact topics like it so
stopping at 1% off from no exact optimum
absolutely it is much much faster 1%
from optimum is orders of magnitude
faster but we're ambitious here we
really want the absolute optimum okay
of course the analysis you can do for
you know relaxed bounds as well and who
knows what you get we haven't done that
so how about zap solvers you remember I
told you earlier one point three two to
the N is the best worst-case theoretical
amount bound for three sets so here we
look at phase transition random three
sets so that's sort of the most famous
case of randomly generated instances has
been studied by statistical physicists
theoretical computer scientists and
mathematicians for decades now some
people use to believe and I think still
do believe that phase transition random
reset captures in some sense the essence
of NP hardness right so what about this
we took three competition winning
solvers for these kinds of instances
Haseley NFS march high and march BR so
those were the three of them of a much
larger number that we considered and
investigated the empirical scaling and
you can see that they are all
exponential but all exponential with
very benign constants very very small
pre factors and very small bases here
compared to the theoretical worst case
and that would explain why nobody is
actually implementing this algorithm by
ahead
because you know a difference between
one point two three one point three two
and one one point zero three is is
humongous right it's really big
okay so what about local search actually
first of all and you know we trained
this here and it did pass the challenge
on trained on 200 to 400 so actually
three set is quite a bit harder than TSP
you can really not solve instances with
thousands of variables random instances
you cannot it's not possible so we
trained our 200 to 400 and then this
passed the challenge at 450 to 550 at
550 you already have hours per run
essentially right if you were willing to
invest months per run you could maybe
push it to 600 and then you would you
would be absolutely topped out and so
you can see when you look at these
bootstrap confidence intervals for the
critical parameter here and they all
overlap and indeed now you can do very
fun things you can see if the real model
were this right and I see whether it
also describes the data generated by
this guy you know is it actually the
case that we can say meaningfully this
guy behaves differently from the model
for this guy and that is a more
technical way of answering the question
you know is the performance difference
between them significant right it is
actually a statistical significance test
and so when you do that you find that
these three are statistically
indistinguishable right so you cannot
make any claim that statistically any of
these solvers is better than any of the
others yeah to some extent but there are
significant differences between them and
actually these ones won the competition
years after this one had appeared so
empirically you know it's this tends to
be a little bit better often enough that
it could win a competition but not often
enough that you can say it with
statistical confidence so it might just
be the competition samples due to which
that happens why it might be a small
enough difference that you would need
millions of instances to tease out
statistical significance what about
local search actually some of the best
theoretical results for 3sat based on
local search algorithms
in fact this this algorithm by hardly at
all that I told you is a local search
algorithm right so it only holds with
high probability which I neglected to
say earlier but I'm telling you now so
there's the famous walks at SK see
algorithm which essentially rekindled
interest in sat in the a community in
the in the early 90s right salmon will
be here later this week so he is
actually one of the people who was
majorly involved and for whom it's
called s we attack in week outs and
Brian Cohen and you can see here to
everybody's great surprise this actually
scales essentially cubic right on phase
transition random 3sat and not only that
but the two sort of much more recent
local search algorithms prop set and
balance set also scare is a scale
essentially cubically and once again we
can do the bootstrap analysis to be
statistically more significant or more
sophisticated and what you can see here
is the bootstrap confidence intervals
for the exponent here are kind of wide
but they nicely brackets we in all cases
and again there's no statistically
significant performance differences
between those three although in practice
when you look at it this one would be
would win a competition against this one
here pretty much anytime right but it's
not enough the margin is not enough
using our modeling techniques and to
claim statistical significance you would
need many more instances for that yeah
that's a very good question
the main problem with that is that you
would need a complete solver in order to
make sure that you're not throwing out
solvable instances that are too hard for
these guys right don't agree with the
model but that a complete solver cancel
so it's the limitations incomplete
solvers that make it impossible to go
further these ones can go a lot further
and we have done this of course the big
problem with that is the phase
transition already at at 1,000 and you
notice we go to 1,000 here we already go
larger right the phase transition
becomes so sharp that it is you can fall
off in it in an instant right you can
think you're at the phase transition and
you see that you saw 50% of the
instances are 50.3 or something but in
reality you miss the phase transition by
0.01 and 99% of the instances are
solvable and you've just missed it and
that's the problem that's why you can't
confidently without really going out on
a limb go beyond a thousand but in
principle these these solvers of course
can tackle instances a lot bigger you're
quite right still not as big as the TSP
instances that we talked about but but
it's getting there so there's a second
thing I want to talk about now that I've
shown you how to do analysis scaling
analysis in a somewhat more
sophisticated way and that second thing
has to do with design and Kevin will
actually talk more in detail about that
I don't have the time today but I
thought I wanted to tell you a little
bit how the two things connect so if
this is an algorithm many algorithms
actually have parameters right including
all the ones that I mentioned today and
these parameters can be numerical
parameters that you can just you know
slide essentially and they can be
categorical parameters like
pre-processing techniques to switch on
and off heuristics ABC that you can
switch between or freely combine things
like that and we all know that by
fiddling with this we can make this guy
behave better or worse right on giving
distributions of inputs so we can go
from low performance to high performance
and so Kevin I and quite a few other
people have worked over the last decade
or so on automating this process quite
successfully I want to show you a few
quick examples and you in Kevin will
show you more and different ones so this
is ling-ling a state-of-the-art solver
and software verification
instances the default configuration and
a configured configuration takes only
about a day or so to configure this
thing and what you see is that we get up
to two orders of magnitude better on
many of these instances right so this is
pretty big
on average we go from 3 3 PU seconds to
0.16 so these are all pretty easy
instances but you have to solve many of
them in realistic context and software
verification so not just one and
actually the rank of the solvers and
when you configure that may change very
much so in a competition where this
thing I mean its default configuration
competed with many others it was
actually ranked fourth once you
configured all of them fairly with the
same budget this one ranked first right
so if you dismiss practically an
algorithm just because it didn't win it
might just be that you couldn't
configure it to win here are SEAPLEX
which we heard about earlier which has
lots of parameters on wildlife corridor
design conservation biology instances
default versus optimized again you can
see that's up to three orders of
magnitude better average speed-up of
52.3 and here's a fun little thing that
I did together with Don Knuth when he
finished his part on of this art of
computer programming for Sat now you
might wonder you know if somebody like
Don really thinks deeply about a Sat
solver and builds one then probably
there isn't much potential for making it
better by switched by it by choosing
parameters and that's exactly what Don
thought and then Don and I intersected
at some point in the SAP conference and
I gave a talk not quite like this but I
talked about algorithm configuration and
he went like well you know maybe you
should see whether you can squeeze
something out of my algorithms I don't
think you'll be able to but why don't
you try right and so you will see if you
if you read his book that he has an
algorithm called Sat 13 that kind of
captures the state-of-the-art Sat solver
architecture very much like Ling Ling
and I actually trained us on instances
just from down here and Don made a nice
set for it and then when I evaluate
admitted but quite a bit better here
they've got even better up here it's
still you know it wasn't as significant
as an others but the solver doesn't have
many parameters and in most on canoes
who actually manually optimize it at the
default down here right
so it went he's measuring running to him
in MEMS that went from 0.57 2.40 Giga
ohms and
GigaOM is something like 25 seconds on a
contemporary machine and that was a 41%
speed-up and Don was very happy with
that he was very surprised and so then
we actually took these instances and
this is how it connects to scaling we
took this configuration and ran it on
the instances that he was really
interested in these are called the TA or
CPD testing instances that the solver
had never seen before that were
different in structure and that were
much larger okay and what you can see is
that on these instances it actually
performed quite well there's one outlier
here which both Don and I are not happy
with but not everything works well on
everything right but on average this
actually came down quite a bit and
essentially had a 36% speed-up which Don
was really happy with okay so the
question now however is can automatic
configuration improve the scaling
behavior right can I get to a to a
better functional model significantly
better constants for example and that is
the idea behind configuration for
scaling and so just very quickly I want
to show you some results that can be
achieved and without telling you too
much how it's actually done because
that's pretty involved but what you can
do is this EAX algorithm and the default
I showed you before scales like this if
you optimize it it actually scales like
this and as you can see here and this
constant here which is of course the
critical one went down quite a bit and
these models here actually passed the
challenges at most of these sizes here
so in some sense this is statistically
meaningful the scaling behavior right
you can go further using so-called
parameter scaling models what are they
well sometimes when you scale up an
algorithm to larger in size some of its
parameters need to be modified as well
need to be cranked up or cranked down
right I'm sure you can all think of
cases like this and of course if you
know in advance you can renormalize the
the parameters and then just fit
constants but often you don't know in
advance and parameter scaling models
figure that out automatically using
machine learning essentially right and
so we use these parameter scaling models
automatically learned with configuration
for scaling behavior and what we get
then is this is what we had before with
these PSM optimization we are
actually get down to polynomial behavior
for eggs which is pretty surprising and
the polynomial behavior I should tell
you is slightly under estimating what's
really happening but better than any
good exponential model that we can find
that is automatically findable right
that's so there's a little gap opening
here and we're still hoping to close
that so to wrap this up my take-home
message is this in cases where you can't
prove a nice theorem about the Big O
scaling behavior or the constants in
cases where the constants hidden by Big
O are of interest to you and often they
are there are ways of obtaining
statistically sound models of empirical
scaling behavior once that have a
statistically underpinning that you know
is no guarantee it's statistical after
all but much better than just curve
fitting or producing a little table we
can configure algorithms automatically
for a good performance scaling so not
just in the supervised machine learning
sense where you have a representative
sample from your underlying distribution
you optimize for that which is already
very cool
and you'll hear more about it tomorrow
before lunch from Kevin but you can
actually do this so that you can have
some statistical confidence that at
higher instant sizes that you've never
seen before
you will also be significantly better
and the gap will grow which is a nice
thing to be able to do and the methods
that I've talked about here are very
broadly applicable there's nothing
specific about them - satis TSP to MIT -
anything right you can use this for you
algorithm and certainly further
improvements are possible we are working
on some hopefully as other people pick
this up you will you will figure out
more the final remark I want to say and
I want to make us this and this area of
empirical algorithmics I like to use the
symbol here for it not just because it's
kind of an Ian kind of a name but
because philosophically it's an
inductive mode of reasoning that's
underlying the idea right and the
inductive mode of reasoning is I show
you an algorithm let's say Concord and I
show you empirical evidence that the
scales in a certain way and then
hopefully that inspires you to go and
dig into Concord maybe simplify it maybe
dissected and ultimately prove theorems
about some part of it
and that in fact is how theory is done
in most sciences right you make
observations you generalize boldly from
those and then you prove something about
them right so this is the inductive mode
of reasoning and it's very much what's
what inspires empirical algorithmics
this I think is very nicely
complementary and interacts very
benignly and beneficially with algorithm
engineering an algorithm engineering in
my view is something which starts from
theorems and then tries to instantiate
things that the theorems either leave
open or that we feel we need to fiddle
with in order to make the theorems
applicable or the algorithms about which
we've proven something applicable to
practical situations we instantiate this
improve then there exists a variation of
this thing that also works well in
practice right from the general to the
specific so that's the deductive mode of
reasoning and I'm sure that many of you
here prefer that mode of reasoning but I
think there is great complementarity
between the two and switching back and
forth between those like people like
Donald Knuth
and David Johnson have done throughout
their careers is indeed very beneficial
and I find working on this side here is
a lot of fun and hopefully can inspire
some of what's happening over here
so one last thing if you find that
empirical algorithmics might be cool and
interesting I'm working on a little
textbook which will appear with
Cambridge University Press pretty soon
so if you want to read more about these
things you can of course read my papers
or wait a little for this if anybody
seriously interested I'm more than happy
to share drafts it's almost complete now
with this I thank you very much for your
attention and hope you found some of
this somewhat interesting thank you
so one thing that seemed really
interesting I didn't know is that for
exact solving of TSP you said that so
the random instances seem to capture
kind of the same stealing behavior as
all these other things TSP lab now I
mean one could talk about that is for a
particular algorithmic approach or does
it seem to be more than that
so I mean like that's you know that
seemed like that that one thing you've
noticed that for a variety of algorithms
and with what I have and I find it very
curious I'm as astonished by it as you
might be I didn't expect that exactly I
didn't even expect it for Concord our
viewers of the paper that we published
on this two years ago didn't expect it
either and we're rather skeptical but
ultimately convinced I think there must
be something interesting going on here
and of course adversarially you can
construct instances that deviate from
this right you can look carefully at
some of these instances that are
outliers and this little plot that I've
shown you and then make more instances
like that and they will also be outliers
so this is not a result that says it's
always is the case but it tends to be
the case so my feeling is that there
might be a statistical result there that
says largely independently of how you
attack TSP as long as it's a general
purpose 2 TSP algorithm the random
uniform instances seem to be a pretty
good surrogate for the kind of structure
for the kind of behavior that you will
see and it's it's interesting I wonder
how far it goes myself empirically we've
pushed it as far as we could and we
didn't find a real hole in it no obvious
hole now special purpose techniques that
are known to be efficient were very
specially structured tsps I would not
expect at all that this would hold for
them obviously not right because the
structure that they latch on to what
would probably be absent in those
randomly generated instances
I'm asking this because I'm thinking
like machine learning you're choosing
models and then so like when you say
polynomial model we call any times that
guess into the beat yes it is monomial
yes choose quite possibly I mean almost
certainly you would have and the reason
why we didn't is also the reason why you
would expect that that it would fit
better which is that of course you know
from a rich class of models a six
parameter model or a five parameter
model should better should fit better in
principle than a three parameter or a
two parameter model right three things
one after the other yes you are
absolutely right and the method that I
try to share with you today is of course
not restricted to two parameter models
not at all right in fact you could
you're perfectly fine if you have a
hypothesis what the scaling behavior
should be to plug in exactly the model
that you want in fact we did a fair bit
I didn't talk about it today we did a
fair bit of fitting off one parameter
models because we had reasons to believe
that you know something should be fixed
at at some value right you can do that
too ultimately the limitation of the
technique becomes the performance of the
numerical optimization algorithms it
turns out to be the case that at four or
five parameters unless your data is very
clean the numerical fitting runs into
bad local Optima because most numerical
fitting algorithms just guarantee a
local optimum only and even that if it's
a little ill condition can be
problematic right so you need to have
numerical sophistication to push through
that barrier
but it's possible right and in general
that the technique will just work
another thing of course you can do is
you can start with a monomial and you
get a good fit for that and then you
start you know essentially refining your
model by adding more and sort of
iteratively fitting those and that's
also something we've started doing and
that seems to be promising and working
well but you're absolutely right that
there are situations and we can easily
construct them and we would also expect
that they arise naturally of course
we're two parameter models like the ones
that I've shown you would not be the
whole store
definitely so if the if the running
times are the given instant size R or
log normal couldn't you use that to to
do a better fit to your curves you know
do do a do a per instance size inference
based on the law normality yeah related
sort of question is doing a different
scheme maybe you know trimmed trimmed
mean or something instead of median you
know why these particular choices to
robust so so media and just seemed like
the obvious choice I would agree with
you that trimmed means would also be
possible I think media and it's just
more common right and media and I would
claim that media and performance means
something pretty intuitive it means the
performance you see on 50 percent of the
instances including the the 50th
percentile right and so I feel that
that's a pretty nice thing to be able to
say that you know with 0.5 probability
your running time will not be higher
than this statistical variance
you're quite right in my experience here
the major limiting factor is the sample
size not the inference that you are
doing and you're right that by using
more powerful inference you can deal
with smaller samples a little bit better
and then it's the dimeric of fitting as
well which causes a lot of noise so yes
there are definitely tweaks if
statistical stability is your main
objective to improve that a little I
don't think you can improve it a lot on
this data I'm going to trim means for
example now of course the observation
that if you have a distributional
assumption confirmed or not at each
instance size you can exploit that as
absolutely dead on and we didn't do it
because we didn't want to contaminate
our analysis with this assumption to
start with but of course you know once
you have it you can then rework the
analysis and you would probably be able
again to push it a little bit further
now for as clean as distributions as we
see here the median actually is the
empirical median is is a pretty good
thing to plug in compared to something
that's that's based on a fit of the
entire distribution as it turns out so I
don't think you would gain much but
again
I think you're right and suggesting
there are data cases where you could
gain much and even here you might gain a
little if you're willing to make this
assumption upfront a vague question but
given that you can do this configuration
of algorithms right should I be thinking
about how to design algorithms
differently in other words you know try
to think about what the exact right way
to do this is that should I be thinking
what's like the right you know space
with knobs and then turn it over I mean
is there any success in that area or any
lessons disclaimer I didn't pay him to
ask the question maybe Kevin you did
you're absolutely right you couldn't in
fact be more right in light of what you
just argued we have exactly we've been
and we've been advocating for a few
years now something that we call
programming the optimization and the
whole idea is that once you trust that
you have a procedure that can do the
configuration tasks better then you can
manually significantly better write your
approach to algorithm design changes
fundamentally it used to be at least
that's the way I've been brought up and
many of you academically probably as
well it used to be the case that you go
parameters are not so good right so
let's try to make our algorithms
parameter less because users don't like
to fiddle with parameters and that's
true most users don't like it and are
not good at it either and we even found
that most experts like us and on canoes
are not that good at it right and that
means a lot more so the point is once
you believe that general-purpose
algorithm configuration is possible it
changes the way you think about
algorithm designs simply by encouraging
you very much to leave the parameters in
to not make design choices by saying I
run a bunch of experiments and the
constant should be 2.5 because that's
what I have observed until I run out of
patience instead you see I'm going to
call this AI make it a parameter I'll
leave it free I might have some
constraints on it right because I know
that it doesn't make sense to set a to a
million it doesn't make sense to set it
to negative numbers but then I let the
configurator figure it out and I think
our group and other groups as well have
started to really embrace this you can
see this as
some sense the generalization of the
machine learning revolution right why
generalization because now we're talking
about arbitrary algorithms not just
learning algorithms we're talking about
abierto algorithms and you're encouraged
to adapt them to the data automatically
in fact using machine learning
techniques and and and optimization
techniques and if you're interested in
that topic you will very much enjoy
Kevin's talk because he will do what I
neglected to do out of time namely tell
you how this can be done and it's
actually a really interesting and cool
way in how you can make this happen and
get really good results so I sit again
how close are we to what pretty far away
I'd say you know that's that's kind of a
dream but there is an important boundary
that so far we haven't overstepped and I
feel that it doesn't have to be overstep
to do really powerful useful things and
that is the boundary where you are going
from a space that only contains correct
algorithms perhaps even provably correct
algorithms that different performance
can hugely different in performance to
spaces that contain algorithms that
might not be correct so if you wanted to
make your entire code a parameter you
would have to reason about spaces that
contain incorrect programs so then you
have to not only do performance
optimization but also program synthesis
I think that's a phenomenally harder
problem now I do think you know some of
my work is unsatisfiability which can of
course be used for software synthesis
right my feeling is that sometime in the
future by bringing these two lines of
work together and not necessarily me but
but others one could get there but the
way I think about it right now is that
when you develop something that's
performance critical and it's not
obvious what to do and typically it
isn't right then you experiment no
matter what and what we're really saying
is these experiments first of all don't
do them in a haphazard way right don't
do them in ad-hoc ways governed by your
patience and then never commit to
anything hardwired in based on these
limited experiments right do the
experiments automatically and be bold
and using throwing computation
and if you just do that you will open up
enough right so large parts of your code
will still be written by you and it will
be used providing all the nice heuristic
ideas and algorithmic ideas and they
might be taken from the theory
literature for all that we know right
walks that skc is very much inspired by
the results by the random walk result by
papadimitriou right so very good source
of inspiration you throw this all in and
then you let the Machine figure out how
to wire it all up not to get correct
behavior you do that but to get
performant behavior and that's the line
that I would currently draw and I think
on our side of the line where we can
work on this
we feel that we get a ton of traction
pass that line super interesting work
but what we currently do only partially
speaks to that work does that answer it